[Music]
ariana grande has new music but could
she have a newish bling - the singer was
spotted out in NYC grabbing dinner with
her ex Graham Phillips Sunday night
dressed in a preppy look and oversized
coat plaid skirt and white knee-high
boots while the Riverdale actor kept
things cozy in a fitted coat and tan
slacks last month grande and Gramps
spent quality time together days after
Valentine's Day
here they are belting out songs with
their fellow 13 alum elizabeth gillies
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
the two stars go way back in 2008 they
met while starring in 13 on Broadway and
started dating I'm doing two careers at
once I'm working two full-time jobs at
once but it's important to me after
nearly three years together Ariana and
Graham called it quits in 2011 but
remained amicable in 2016 the pair
reunited for the first time since their
split when they hung out in LA with
their former castmates Graham captioned
this pic lille 13 reunion the friendly
exes latest sighting comes less than a
month after ariana was seen reuniting
with her ex Big Sean outside a recording
studio in LA she referenced the rapper
in her hit Thank You next
[Music]
in January the 25 year old tweeted about
staying single for a while writing
spoiler for the rest of this year
probably my life it's no one please
refer back to this tweet for future
questions
Ariana unveiled a new collab with two
chains called ruled the world
she gave us old Hollywood vibes rocking
a feather boa and her signature ponytail
in the music video
like um you're making home
[Music]
seems like Ari has another hit on her
hand she's been dropping Bob after Bop
ahead of her sweetener tour featuring
opening acts like normanni LMA and more
[Music]
then ariana broke pop chart records as
seven rings became her fourth number-one
since July so no matter what I'm
grateful
[Music]